I'm sorry Doctor Who series 12 continues
with fugitive of the Judoon Wow the
non-spoiler section on this one's going
to be shorter than normal because dang
okay
um where do we start
uh okay well let's go broad um overall I
liked it I'm starting to feel
comfortably like orphan 55 was a fluke
because right now it stands out as
anomalously bad and that is comforting
first of all now here's one thing that I
will say and and I won't be the first
one to note it and definitely stew bag
full and in his review of spy fall which
if you haven't seen you should I'll link
him to it in the description
noted how much old material from knew
who that Chibnall
is Crippin from and you know how much
he's just sort of yanking plotlines
ideas concepts that people liked before
and kind of mashing them together and
that is also kind of going on here as
well and as much as I can identify that
and say it's not particularly you know
super bold or original I am enjoying it
and I think I think the feeling I have
for chip know right now chip know some
of what goes on here is kind of pulled
and I'll get to it but I feel like
overall he is
serving as a placeholder he's not he
doesn't feel like he has an overall
vision for the thing but you know what I
think we kind of bashed on him for that
for series 11 this series at least so
far I'm a bit more forgiving of that in
an ideal world you know we would have a
bold visionary showrunner but if we
don't a competent placeholder is not the
worst thing in the world you know there
is such a thing as a journeyman creator
you know it's a term sometimes used
derogatory but it's someone who comes in
does the work gets the job done and does
decently at it and there's plenty of
movies and TV shows that I enjoy that
effectively fall under that kind of
heading not exceptional but enjoyable I
don't want Doctor Who to stay in that
mode but I'm kind of okay with it
especially if it's gonna be as fun as
this is so there's a number of really
big spoiler things that I'm gonna have
to get into relatively quickly try to
think if there's anything else I want to
say I'm I'm kind of I'm getting a little
bit more onboard with how much the
doctor is withholding from the
Companions because it it is a different
dynamic that we've had a little bit the
doctor has not tried to pull the
mysterious I can't tell you things act
with a companion I would say really
since Martha so it's been a while okay
fair enough
um and I'm kind of I'm rolling with it a
bit more I think maybe part of what
threw me off about this sort of being
the shtick that she's being so withdrawn
in terms of do I have any idea what's
going on even a clue of what's going on
with her was that I think I got very
used to Tennant being fairly open by the
end Smith being pretty much an open book
with Amy Capaldi never really holding
back with Clara and and or with Bill so
I think I get
got used to that to the doctor being
more open and sort of rolling that back
was throwing me off I think I think I'm
kind of starting to roll with it a bit
better I do still I do still feel like
the three companions is not benefiting
the show it's just kind of is what it is
they're they're cool
note though deep bug anyone else that
the doctor didn't seem to notice that
her companions were missing like all
three of them like she noticed Graham
briefly and there was a toss away line
the right and says my god he's always
trying to keep up then she never bothers
again and like she goes off on this
whole thing and never clocks that Ryan
and yeas are missing I'm not I'm not
gonna go so far as to call that a fault
or a plot hole and of itself but it's
the kind of thing that like I kind of
hope somebody brings that up and I'm not
sure I can't count on that happening cuz
I'm still waiting for there to be
consequences for Ryan blasting somebody
into the past against the wishes of the
doctor from back in Rosa last series so
this this show hasn't lately hasn't been
great about paying off things that feel
like there should be some fallout to
that but okay yeah I need I need to get
into spoilers so if you haven't seen the
episode why are you watching me go do
that come on back and here we go what
let's start with the spoilery stuff
let's start with Captain Jack's back
baby oh you know it's one of those
things I've I haven't been clamoring to
have him back but I think that's why he
just because I didn't wanted to be
disappointed when he kept not showing up
over and over and over again but it's
one of those things like Oh once you're
back I I now I remember why I miss you
Oh God just that smile and it's it feels
extra this time because when I went to
terrific on last year he was there
I got to meet him and he's so wonderful
and charming and just to see that back
on on screen and dr. who again was
awesome now I wasn't completely caught
off guard by this because I caught
whiffs and rumors that he was going to
be back this series and that it might be
this episode so while I wasn't surprised
by that I was grinning from ear to ear
and like the cheekiness I love I love
what he finds out that the doctors a
woman now his reaction is this I got a C
I'm like yes yes that's the perfect
reaction and like honestly part of me
was a little worried because I don't
think chip Nell has ever written for
Jack before so you know you get nervous
about a character coming back who was
created and heavily used by other show
runners is is he got to come off as
wrong and not quite lining up except
that chip know was pretty involved in
Torchwood so I should have except then
again then again again I didn't like
jack
Torchwood as much because he was much
more dour and sort of buried in his
baggage and it wasn't as fun Doctor Who
jack is fun which this is so yeah oh oh
that feels good definitely digging the
heck out of that that having been said
he we very much have to story track
going on and never the twain shall meet
because we have the reintroduction of
Jack as he keeps plucking the Companions
trying to get the doctor and missing and
then we have the doctor off on her own
thing and as I mentioned failing to
notice that the companions are missing
so as much as I enjoyed Jack it it felt
very detached and I'm not sure there was
a way around that because he is clearly
setting stuff up for things to continue
on in the series now
now let's deal with the other thing
let's deal with Ruth and I'm just gonna
have to call her Ruth because I can't
call them both the doctor just for sake
of clarity first off
love the outfit I really hope I see some
people cause playing that one when I get
to Gallifrey one I mmm
I dug that it's it here's the thing I'm
not sure how original I would say the
concept is but honestly this is the kind
of thing that I've kind of wondered in
the back of my mind for a long time if
doctor who would ever be able to pull
off the closest we've ever come to the
idea of meeting a supposedly pot or
possibly future doctor during the
current doctors run that was teased as a
possibility in the next doctor that
David Tennant special but even that one
it was you Clark pretty early on that
that wasn't really that what was
happening and something else was going
on and the performance given by david
morrissey was a very overblown
interpretation of the doctor and never
really felt viable as the real deal
whereas Ruth yeah yeah she's kind of got
a mashup
going of I would say a little bit of
Whitaker and I'm not just saying that
because they're both women like there
there are deliberate similarities
between them you know as and beyond just
them syncing up on their lines but they
both kind of got that stubborn
pigheadedness going that you know
somebody telling them this is a bad idea
well I'm gonna do it anyway so they both
got that so she feels like kind of
almost a marriage of Whitaker and
Capaldi cuz she's much more she's much
grouchier for one thing which I kind of
dug the seeing the doctor or what might
be that will deal with the possibilities
of what she is in a bit this is not
gonna be heavy fan theory on my part cos
it's not really my thing
but I'll talk through a few
possibilities when we get a little bit
further into it but seeing the doctor
with the gun that does throw me up but
again it gets commented on by Whitaker's
doctor so that's the kind of thing like
okay you can have it but acknowledge
that it's off I think I like the design
of Ruth's TARDIS better than Whitaker's
that's gonna annoy me a little bit so
the the build up to it was pretty cool
because you know we've got the the
fugitives from the Judoon and we have
the Judoon back and actually pretty well
handled I was nervous about that because
I felt like after that first appearance
in Smith and Jones that the show and
subsequent appearances I kind of lost
the threat of them being mercenaries
more than they are actually police
because I'd seen the Sarah Jane
Adventures at had one Judoon it was very
much played for comedy and I'd seen you
know then backing up the shadow
Proclamation but if the shadow
Proclamation is supposed to be like all
legit why are they hiring out to the gym
seemed weird this felt much more in line
like they're they they have rules that
they follow but it's so that they can
complete their contract and get paid so
I I kind of I'd like that we got the
more mercenary sense to them also props
to the mask the lip movements much
better than they were first Mithun Jones
back in the day that it's really they've
really nailed the mouth movements
fitting the words that are said
especially in English so props to the
animatronic folks they really they've
really done some really impressive
improvements on that mask and the
movement on it so absolute props to that
so the the reveal I did figure after
Ruth busted the glass that I saw the
thing I'm like okay so we're dealing
with the Time Lord thing figure that
right off then the doctor uncovered
the TARDIS I'm like oh no no no no no
and then Ruth walks up and says I'm the
doctor I'm like okay now I kind of said
I've always kind of liked the idea of
them introducing the future doctor
before they actually take over the role
in figuring well that'll never happen
they'll never be able to pull that off
um and I still don't think they will
because I don't think that's what we're
actually dealing with but I like that
they are letting us think that that
might be what we're dealing with I like
that it's being leaned interviewed
because like I said closest we came to
this sort of concept was the next doctor
and that didn't really go all in on the
idea this is and I find it interesting
again though it's worth pointing out
this is not the most original thing in
the world for Doctor Who because it is
cribbing a lot of known elements the
Judoon are on earth looking for a
fugitive that looks human but isn't
scanning people I mean they are doing
the same stick they did in Smith and
Jones and you know someone who doesn't
realize that they're a Time Lord reveal
it's utopia again yeah you know this
sort of stuff happening it's it is these
little elements cribbed from better on
stories but they're kind of remixed and
they're put together in a way that at
least in the good parts of this series
so far in spy fall and in this there and
nikola tesla's night of terrorists to a
certain extent they are mashed together
in a way that they are complementing
each other
or if in 55 let's just not deal with out
right now please but so because there is
something to be said because I'm sure
the detractors will just say oh it's
unoriginal therefore it's no good like
no you can have something on original
but still have it be good because you're
taking known ingredients and doing them
in a slightly different way and if you
pick the right known ingredients then
hey let's have a good time and I am
having
time with this now let's talk
possibilities here right now I feel like
the most likely possibility is that
we're dealing with some sort of split
timeline thing which i think is gonna
factor into the master as well and would
also possibly answer the question of
where this master falls in the masters
timeline which I already did a video on
because the question before was is Oh
before or after Missy I think we may be
looking at the possibility that always
parallel to Missy the same way Ruth is
parallel to the doctor I think that they
are effectively the same incarnation but
somehow we got a split so if you want a
point of reference on that think back to
the valley rd because here's the thing
that people always tend to forget about
the valley are the valley are was a
possible iteration of the doctor so
there is this thread that has been
planted at various points that how the
doctors gonna regenerate there are
multiple possibilities of how that might
happen and if something went wrong
somewhere along the line that basically
caused two possibilities to happen or if
we're just dealing with parallel
universe is starting to collide which I
suppose is the other possibility but
that would still effectively be the same
thing we're dealing with the same
incarnation you know whatever followed
on directly from Capaldi but two
different possibilities of how that
played out and what that looks like and
I think that maybe the same thing going
on with the master that as with the
doctor
assuming I'm right at all what you'll
probably not but that's my first
instinct in terms of how I think this is
playing out now where does it go from
here I don't know it throws me off a
little bit that they introduced a
Cyberman thing because I feel like we're
juggling a lot already because we've got
the master back we've now got
the Ruth doctor thing we've got the
whole question of Gallifrey is it
destroyed is it not you know where does
the doctor fit in and all this we've got
plenty of stuff to like be picking up
the trail and plus the timeless child
mystery box thing I'm not sure that it's
a good idea to plant another thread on
top of that by dropping this lone
Cyberman thing I could go either way on
that I mean we'll see how it plays out I
worry that they're they're starting to
interweave too many plot threads a bit
like they have too many companions but
um overall I had fun with this and it's
got me wondering and like I said I don't
really do theory like the idea that I
just threw out in the course of this
that's about the most worked out thing
I've got for this but this is probably
Chibnall equivalent of going big and
going bold and I'm enjoying it it's a
remix of early ideas but it's sometimes
remixes work and I did enjoy this for
the most part and my complaints are
largely nitpicky I do think that
Chibnall is kind of playing a dangerous
game because what if people decide they
like the Routh doctor better than
Whittaker that's always the kind of
gamble with trying to pull the trigger
on this style of storyline so who the
heck knows but I want to see what's next
there's a lot of elements in play right
now of course it looks like we're
setting up for the next episode to be
rather detached from the stuff that's
been going on a bit like how or from 55
and nikola tesla those were detached
from things that were continuing on
because while this has not been tied
directly into the stuff with the master
i feel like it's going to because at
least the topic came up so
here's what I'll say in terms of ongoing
season Ark I'm actually kind of liking
the handling of this a little bit better
than modern era doctor who tends to do
because when I complain about the
mystery box style that's usually when
it's just a phrase or a word or some
sort of signifier that we just see or
hear over and over and over again and we
have no idea what it is until the finale
happens this while it is going a couple
episodes at a time not giving us much of
anything you know it is still giving us
something every couple of episodes as
opposed to just stringing us along and
give us nothing until the finale so I
know okay spy fall here's some initial
nuggets and then you know or from 55
nikola tesla oh here's some more and
we'll probably go one or two episodes
without getting a ton of new info that
ties into this for a little bit but i
could also be wrong about that and I'm
excited to see whether I am or not
here's one thing I'll say about this
series of Doctor Who it has got me
excited for new episodes again it
doesn't have to be the best in the world
to be able to do that but it's doing
something right at least by me I'm
excited to see what's next
and I hope that it can build and
continue to build in the direction that
it's going with remixes I D is taking
threads and notions that have been done
before but just weaving them together
somewhat differently some people will
say the show should be big and bold and
be completely new not every showrunner
can do that that would be great
that would be preferred but if we're not
gonna get that I will take this because
I am enjoying it definitely enjoying it
more than series 11 so there you go
fugitive from the Judoon
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something on the
comments let's talk about it there's the
usual stuff to do I have a patreon of
course I do
plus you know links to Barry's so
to media I'm on I've got an Instagram
for council of geeks now other stuff
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah there's all
that stuff that you can do but you also
don't have to do any of it I'd
appreciate it but at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meeting and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]